uh let's go to dr julie marina on all of
this a member of the cdc advisory
committee uh two of the director barbara
wood johnson foundation executive vice
president um
doctor if i could start out on a more
general question if you don't mind some
confusion as to whether covet is here to
stay many medical experts with whom i
talk are saying that it will become part
of our lives much like the annual flu
shot where are you on this
yeah hey neil thanks so much for having
me today
i think it is possible that uh covet is
here to stay
it's not clear for certain but it does
look like that's possible what i would
say though is when people are raising
this question of are we just we should
just accept this as the new normal is
that what we're experiencing right now
with omicron is not something that we
want to accept as the new normal we have
incredibly high rates of disease with
many people being hospitalized and even
young children being hospitalized at
this point and it's not something that
we want to be living with we really need
to optimize the interventions and make
sure that people are getting vaccinated
and doing everything possible to
minimize transmission and minimize
disease
now with endocrine one of the things i
find so startling about this doctrine
i'm sure you asked it a lot we had four
million cases in just the past week
versus four million cases in the first
six months of the pandemic itself yet
we're told the overwhelming majority of
these cases are relatively
mild at least by comparison do you agree
with that
yeah i mean that's what the data are
telling us right now that there's this
incredibly high surge of diseases of
people getting sick but when you compare
the number of cases to those that are
being hospitalized and those that are
dying
the numbers just don't compare it's
really clear that people aren't getting
as sick aren't getting hospitalized like
they did in prior waves of the pandemic
that's not to say that this isn't
serious though because the numbers are
just the total numbers are so high of
people getting sick our hospital systems
are really really stressed and we have
to take this seriously
you know this new uh variant ihu i guess
it's called doctor
should we be worried about
that i think with all you know
throughout this pandemic what we've seen
is the emergence of various variants and
it's critical for us to keep a close eye
on them and to look at the first
question is how transmissible are they
the other question to ask is how bad is
the disease that they're causing is this
causing a really serious disease and
then the other question to ask really is
how effective our treatments and our
prevention measures in preventing
transmission of these variants and so
it's important to keep a keen eye on
what's happening and what's emerging but
also to answer those critical questions
so we know how best to respond
you know doctor uh modernist ceo was
saying that there may be a need for a
fourth covet shot
this comes at the same time israel has
instituted an additional booster so four
shots in all to deal uh with i guess
everything from the original uh
covet and delta and all the rest and now
to omicron
but where does it end
how many shots how many boosters
so this goes back to the question that
you asked me originally is you know omer
or is covet here to stay and i think we
don't really know the answer to that
question if the virus does seem to
continue to circulate and we have new
variants that are emerging then
vaccination may become part of our
annual routine just like flu vaccine but
i think it's too early to say that at
this point when the modernist ceo is
talking about a fourth dose it could be
we're talking about additional boosters
of the same vaccine but it could also be
about a different uh form of the vaccine
that protects against different variants
and so i think at this point it's merely
speculation and it's too early to really
make that call
dr marita very good catching up with you
and answering all of these obnoxious
questions i just wanted to know and you
had answers for all of them much
appreciated thank you
my pleasure thanks neil all right dr
marita on all of that hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else